hello a breather yeah you know God told
us up there Hummel oh yeah he's going to
speak in Korean and I'll be his
interpreter for this event
Anamika pokey button timing go sometimes
idiot when young see Chinese every meter
look at tourism clear determination
comes out the media come case I didn't
you seen moe double kiddo come today
good afternoon my name is Lee Jae Myung
mayor of song Nam city in South Korea
first of all I would like to thank
professor Dasher for this opportunity
and I would like to express my deepest
thanks to all of you here today yo boo
boo boo none is Arabic hakuna matata
hakuna young guru location young I
understand that everyone here has a deep
interest in the tech sector where you
are currently working or conducting
research in a wide range of field you
don't that yet thank you sir okay behind
go tiny want or some wonky overcome
Miyagi done and territory magician guys
in Telugu I think it is informally on
some video crew younggu sorry Rory some
technical data and she taking away
Romina I myself have never developed any
special technology nor have I ever
attempted to attempt it to run a
business but as I understand it the
reason I will speak invited to speak
here is to share my experience regarding
pangyo techno belly to illustrate the
role of government for sustaining
success in the tech industry remote you
can never mean then take a damn you our
loan or decided to mess up would you
some help
tango tech nobility and or the other one
day Eva Lopez oh sorry I get home didn't
wanna get parameter I know each of you
have taken valuable time from your busy
schedules to be here and so I hope these
discussions will prove to be meaningful
I also hope that this presentation will
give you a better understanding of what
pangyo techno Valley is and that we may
be able to develop mutually beneficial
relationships Yoshi Valley northern
Mongolia to never go to heaven and
Egyptian Eden and to keep on him attack
2015 as significant in Korea marking the
70th anniversary of independence from
the rule of imperialism you who hung up
soon jadyn and champion callamezzo
damming when can get a party and I mean
serious I'm Chuck we underestimate the
effects of colonization and the fallout
from the Korean War that soon followed
were disastrous for my country however
history shows that Korea overcame this
hardships to realize a thriving
democracy and economic prosperity I mean
we oksanen Legatum abundant potent
Jasmina the entire world has taken
notice of Korea success is rising to the
challenge
the other one dreamily German German
bottoms are on guitar and sang a nimitta
you may or may not have noticed but I am
actually handicapped
only she did it what what karamatsu go
Kong Junkins Angus how do you defend
America
kikyo's even Chang Amita Colin WA
Sangamon orange terracotta hit them well
dunya semi-auto difficult youth and I
used to work in a factory for more than
12 hours a day after graduated from
elementary school in that Factory
I got into an accident where my arm got
caught in the machine leaving me with my
handicap poverty and handicap were the
most difficult hardships I had to suffer
when I was young Grima Chicka mr. radik
young cousin Quintana plan ro Cucamonga
I'm gonna pee on them then totin yes
Peter however confronting those things
as challenges to overcome was exactly
what motivated me to become the person I
am today general including you saw her
go Xavier Kenan XE months are Ramadan
hold on again how many juxtaposing cubic
he's a consummate politician well it
occurs to me that I've since learned
that people are the key component what
ultimately keeps our society going
people are important and workers must be
perfectly compensated for the level work
to guarantee the sustainability of a
company hola kyon-kun they get a Gerson
Akira chaturanga see some gum yes Holly
Raymond and chocolate and go to Hannah
Smith
and I've also learned that building a
system to give opportunities to those
who have failed to bounce back after
setbacks is what creates future success
stories saganaki running to Chino
sang-hwa human you come here wanting one
Gator Yugi heard a song sung your
collagen is used Amita you're often
wondering is a key of a angular Takeda
1000m it'll maintain a mutually
cooperative and complementary
relationship between society and
business creates an incredible
synergetic effect because of this type
of relationship I feel that describing
the business environment as an ecosystem
as a fitting metaphor eternal torture a
type transantiago jamming Angelica and
Keewatin are Auto genius Mita hideo
namagachi go now open a geothermal
inhibited one I am proud of my country
and I have a cheap thus far the key word
behind these successes is challenge this
is the same for all the countless
entrepreneurs who plunge headfirst into
this unforgiving world armed with
nothing but a single idea yes just on a
pumpkin of Elliott when I saw sometimes
you guys she don't toge anybody angry
sir gentlemen I will now describe the
challenges that song am city faced by
telling you the story of pangyo techno
Valley somewhat poetic level in check
and I see is a mandarine cotton Silicon
Valley modern can come up with a meeting
out of the innovation clusters recently
established in Asia pangyo techno Valley
in Sonam is the one whose model is
recognized mostly closely resemble
Silicon Valley
Sasha pangolins her in Japan Kyung in
Lompoc on economy again convenient
height ability so country in day no
although Ponyo is located with an
extensive our technology belt just stop
the soul as actual area is just over a
quarter square mile
Linda yo Senor boondocks in one and
Samsung Nina it you got to shake it
shake we kill Carissa so timing would
happen a some company he said it some
done guilty one identity anymore eco
with your product - because I don't
gamble yume de sao pauio techno Valley
is home to the subsidiaries of some of
the world's leading companies such as
Samsung and LG which I'm sure you've
heard of there are also many other
pioneering high tech ventures and RD
Institute's that represent Korea making
up an impressive total around around
60,000 people working in 800 Stephanie
company's game economy in the diamond
Armour in Lebanon say getting
inconvenient negotiate a GameCube movie
tango Tony Mirra if you have even the
slightest interest in games you will
know that Korea is a strong presence in
the gaming world seven of the 10 major
Korean gaming companies are located in
Pangolin and their two Takahama Diego si
plus a 2 son cotton in the human pincher
capital e hunger or to hurt on with
their religion Anthony tamara semina
a pongo has come under the spotlight as
being an attractive spot for investors
as well because it is the main area of
activity for many well-known VC firms
such as the Korean Angels business
angels Association as a plus investment
management - some investment and many
others each our own and Japan Coonan I
am in Google oh ma ha check way uptown
tonight is an oculist thorough
initiative with MIT today Ponyo is
recognized as the most dynamic tech
industry cluster
not just in Korea but in all of Asia
America madam Yun ku Norville in Kiev a
top RT zanta Gannon Shambu Jong shik is
humble overseas Amida Woody's homonym
she walk and get on precisely speaking
the decision for companies to move into
pangyo techno belly may be the result of
government policies not the voluntary
choices of those companies Tonga techno
Valley was only made possible with a
great deal of energy and effort invested
by sanam city and the entire congi
province in which our city is located Oh
Domingo casuaiiy gangnam style' tonight
to all of you know the Korean singer psy
who sang the Gangnam style you notice a
colonic on lemon so they're condemning
that mingo chechu a
Gangnam in that song refers to a
district in Seoul that also happens to
be where Korea's first tech startups
were founded damming with an Bohannon
could it was hello Couture gentleman
pinche obey woman can amuse me
Gangnam is home to these companies that
had faced many challenges but finally
succeeded for the first time in Korea
sometimes children borrow benches on ok
condoms and song them city's first
challenge was to recreate the miracle of
Gangnam in the high-tech world
Olivia saw campin boppin guru hana in
welcome Bob isn't against Mita
Michigan is on screen and you don't
worry dr. Olivia ships urban jungle
Thank You cheeky Mesa congressmen
managed to piss media in order to do
this we decided to connect Pongo and the
condom area to create a single living
sphere a distance that used to take over
one hour to travel was reduced to just
14 minutes thanks to the construction of
a new Express subway line this also had
the added benefit of decreasing the
psychological distance between Kangnam
and song nam gomes da da Jung Bogota
Myeongdong she gave up on yourself
Cunegonde hello konami worship Oh soo
Jin a cargo brought 20 token group a
cube a cube you much would you go
not only was the travel time shortened
but the government also took part in
public land development projects making
property available to companies at half
the price level of property found in
Gangnam even though they're located
within the same price zone this provided
a way for companies to reduce their
opportunity cost creating benefits to
move in Kalibak Milan given pangoro
Ichigo Cogan solar to Morristown Network
early channels physical or doctor
tomorrow
Ketchikan Hong Kong could use a meter as
a result many
companies that relocated topango were
able to do so without losing the
seoul-based network that they had built
up over the years as well as cultivating
a cheaper yet more pleasant environment
I'm beginnin head on pango chemin de
negocios Amita the next stage was to
create a new miracle of Ponyo huh Mugen
I hope she won so visitors won't have
wasted on governments in Korea I usually
offer variety of corporate services okay
what is uncommon son of Japan and um
click on even the result however song
I'm adopted a more proactive attitude
early on and created an exclusive
organization called the song industry
promotion agency that provides a host of
services to attract companies either run
Silicon Valley a temperature on key of
kung fu on Changwon a service or a young
Gekko mentoring Antonio saw some giant
universe Amita you don't system watch
I'm go get your bangs I'm putting a
sword is how long she got hung up with a
meter mark Stanford University's
relationship with Silicon Valley the
agency provides information and services
for companies and promotes growth and
development to mentoring programs with
the assistance of such a system Sonam
has become recognized as the most
business-friendly city in the country
second oberliga which has emotional
hunger get a Chinese kitchen table or
discomfort internal she percent in Saudi
Arabia so no point in which I was in
song Nam city where pangyo techno Valley
is located both a high tech focus
creative workforce of 33 percent a
higher number compared to Seoul's
27 percent get on the talk wave is open
7 to 0 there
Toria mantua certainty one system Coco
gear pump on in Jaipur concur optimal
ozone
condom on Cuomo Cambodian and EP Rosa
Frankish Naga and original song name
cheaper real estate extensive support
system which pulled talented individuals
and easy access to existing network
structures have come
mine to create the miracle Pongo that
has transcended from as good as Gangnam
- better than Gong Nam you go to Rome
JEA pinchable money - coming up on ghost
knowledge with one girl one terminal
veteran saravana German itg or the
middle ro III Hungary opting to give oh
talking to the inky of st. a commander
with the group of people who are leading
the miracle Pongo and bringing about a
second venture boom our professional
tech CEOs in their early 40s
these individuals are the ones who are
fostering a dynamic and creative
business ecosystem in Punggol Segundo
anger technology and kyokotsu Jam Drona
with a song a song long she can get
awkward watch on Google hunky I'm gonna
check on the validity of our cable
should you know it currently more and
more companies want to move into pokeo
techno Valley so somnom City congi
province and the Korean government are
all working together to push forward
plans to construct the second Pongo and
the vicinity yeah
genin yes I want you got young hey
they're havin one come Jenga
talk see ya Nira Radia walk home indeed
I wasn't a comida co-opting Yocto - yes
aunty Munro discussing it I believe the
new direction for capitalism should be
not be unfair competition and monopoly a
rather consideration and coexistence no
company can survive just on its own
accomplishments sorry Zach even each
other can we look Joe Colombo to copy be
on your way
it was what kill Sumida thank you madam
Yun your image in what under innocence
and she gave me that it's a societal
infrastructure does not grow and develop
along with the company that everyone
will ultimately fail in the end it only
makes sense that a tree cannot bear
fruit if the land dries up yeah yeah
Paro jungseok our young bear your car is
Mira she's young age and kosher salami
on protons I don't even care reporting
it to Amita there is a role that
politics and the government can play
here they must make sure the market
functioning as a chippy without being
distorted and they must also guarantee
wider opportunities for new challengers
go para ship Erica Jong ho aashiqui Oh
Orson and the malum and rheometer
kokuboro Cho of attention Chiquita
Porsche Canyon de Yoker Amita more than
anything they must create a safety net
for those who suffer setbacks can bounce
back without crashing on the ground this
is the role that politicians and city
planners such as myself must play young
woman in there that's the most important
part
krisily miss Hong Kong key open and
honest thoughtful key over her so much
chicken goes in your finger to nobility
is the primary focus of pangyo techno
Valley is not only to continue to
support existing companies that have
already succeeded here but also to help
invigorate those who muster up the will
to found startup companies arena and
it'll be a venture capital gardener
kyocho ki-chun of kusuda chang of cubic
history Lacroix from John Connon someone
at Penn Kaiser in creating an assistant
so much young gopis gentlemen draw when
you're halfway Sumida eunjin Boone hang
in there ships are gay yes Tokyo get to
each other in order to do this we have
cooperated with VC firms to found and
operate the song nom to some specialized
startup Support Center where those as
assessed as having potential are
nurtured for growth for the past two
years the center has helped raise over
17 million u.s. dollars for 14 startup
companies Crego idea regarding human
redesign constructing illogical
Constantinian idea coriander coconut
open content Sakura alley with on a
program though we always omit a program
called content Korea also support
startups and access on consultant for
citizens with business ideas helping
people with potential to promote their
ideas and attract interested parties
Korean design is all within a stone for
a start the accelerator program acronym
uncle
benchmarking aqueous media here addendum
katana hungry Miyagi company we are also
highly interested in Stanford Stark axe
accelerator program and are studying it
in a focused way I hope there will be an
opportunity to discuss ways that will
make it possible to join forces in pan
go-go Prado she jang yi-jeong ha cuando
su llamada more than anything it is
important to secure market fairness a
bodega Bienvenue something she's done go
to taman ayun useful peggy gonna hollow
roads had a mortar should make a
guatemalan on her own odenza washroom so
venture genome chennai with me that
there is a flood of new challengers and
small and medium-sized companies that
are unfairly losing out on opportunities
to grow this is because their technology
is either being taken away confirm them
or they're unable to find their place in
the monopolistic wave structure market
that was designed to benefit a few large
conglomerates could ago when joe 11g
obese heroin protons a trainer bacteria
or a commander alone sorry for the
trouble in camuto BG Amita there are
also many companies that climb the
ladder to success letters that were
built and put into place only to kick
them away once they have scaled them to
prevent new challengers from emerging
shikaku Zanon hunger technically
obedience Conahan
she jumps in take a meat ax home Johnson
get a wagon idealizing towed and John
startup cure be eating in San Girolamo
such is Okanagan kioku John hug you
young
pieces open Amita in my mind the Ponyo
techno belly of the future is a fair
market ecosystem fairness is the
prerequisite for new challengers or
startup companies to succeed in building
sustainable business beyond a one-time
success Ruben Sierra Dan Cronin jock
boudin hey Mira Pangaea cabeza
Kumgang monitoring system couch Akershus
comida - aunt hong kong van or louisa
quixote under sheetrock - and
anti-injunction RC Sameera
a public monitoring system could be
built in order to prevent the
conventional malpractice against small
medium-sized venture companies and and
startups from happening so Bryce types
of policy support could be also put into
effect to help these companies defend
themselves in solidarity
Karuna but upon you taking when J
Haggard second each way put on he
knocked jumped Misaki ever done for the
wrong done whenever kun on the
transmitter
however the solution to the very guts of
a matter is completely blocking
monopolies wrongdoings and unfair
customs again small medium-sized
companies in the first place you know
it'll be a secure plan according civil
case and ago in Chile which is o'connell
dope in the system it shouldn't be
wasted for this matter we are preparing
a system that can improve transaction
methods between companies as well as
increase the sustainability of startups
yodhraj ing huh Mugen
I'm gonna take your VM so Gilbert on ya
sadati na I was watching in Turkey at a
cha'aka it charted or Oklahoma's Amiga
currently in Korea when the government
or a conglomerates draws up contract and
procurement or outsourcing form through
small and medium sized companies it is
commonly said that the lowest price wins
your aren't you done jae-joong to Utah
don't usually cook the Harmon brothers
you watch a man say you don't observing
children is assumed an intrusive into
giving although it is just justified to
increase the efficiency of public
finance or maximize profits for
shareholders in actuality the value of
countless small and medium-sized
companies frequently suffers from this
kind of beating method Haruki Oguma heo
jung da-jung kabocha motive all Calcutta
at the man she wanted and joy Mangano
could've owned one culture
comedy hmm I didn't though not at
respective so mrs. Calvo nearest I wanna
seem in the peerage youngest John Calvin
Jo grow tonin to market mulatto conduct
your own to wait upon the Jasmine if a
company and its products are devalued in
this
as employees will suffer from low wages
and employment instability attempts at
cost reduction will only deteriorate the
quality of the products further
ultimately it is the consumer of these
products who will suffer although it
might be possible to save a bit of money
this system doesn't really benefit
anyone in the end solution y también
tiene que cuando dongjun shimamoto
commander questionin Chacon going to
large area with scimitar in song we are
designing a fair public procurement
system as a reform measure to fix the
existing unreasonable one emphasizing
social value that can promote the
happiness of all those concerned joban
changu of acculturation Commendation a
coruña passing on egan Kohanga England
illegal Shinji's Latrobe you don't get
to name the system fairly value it's a
value of small and medium-sized
companies and startups while prompting
those companies to use the profits that
are generated as a result to increase
employment and wages as well as invest
in new technology we known each other -
Monroe sangria Tokyo quiet chef ever
Tony Hsieh knock you up because I want
John Jay King to come don't change
thanks to this system and agreements
with companies of all sizes in Pongal we
plan to promote social compromise for
the ultimate happiness of all citizens
and company workers or in other words
the happiness of the community so Marsha
consciousness ammonia Samira Jason 30
teams are Tanya some damn she she Jamuna
bangin Auto
gong-gong Sonia can model some of the
same attack I will successfully
reelected as mayor of Salaam and in my
inaugural address I declared that my
administration will focus on
strengthening public service Samina
Genki ones o grupo Jung today called
rip-roarin got hung Angus was social
settings how is a gap terrible go home
young gentleman tango she caught him in
jaii Eagle pedometer I believe that
protecting the basic rights of citizens
and those who are marginalized by
society such as handicapped people and
minorities and fostering an environment
of fair competition are the paths to
guarantee the interest of all citizens
good ego will get a checkup children
Osman Gazi ro Chun we okay jungseok a
local mr. Mehta and I believe the role
of politics and government today is to
follow that path aggressively Imagineer
some lamb cheese and honey in here the
human water can take apart more
chocolate then who should you check
wonders how arises to me that recently
some lamb City held an event where the
city held citizens by paying off
long-held that's to lenders and
symbolically burning the IOUs insulin
your avocation world item young CB you
wish tucked in rolling shipbuilding
doing a song ambien what did Amita he
humbly ends our tuna so yeah come pick
you Maggie
hey thank you at the Sumida Cano it turn
cuz I'm gonna say no comment chicken
though this event was Hong lungs version
of the rolling jubilee which as you may
know began with the Occupy Wall Street
movement through this one event around
300 people were given the opportunity
for new start thinking about the joy of
those people still makes my heart warm
turn on each occasion Europe under
moduga
challenging is a Sunni wonky clicking a
curb or honking an area walk home
tonight on Monica digital parameter
Commission is how the system was a
architect a turbine Dromgoole don't go
Toto Muharram today oh Jenny can I get a
question whether it is my wish that each
one of you present today may be
successful in all of your endeavors and
that you may adopt the outlook of
sharing that success through
consideration and coexistence once this
idea becomes a well-established social
system it will be possible for not only
all of you but many others to face their
challenges head-on I'm Katalin of stuff
kakashi come to me come let us all take
on this challenge together thank you so
much for your kind attention
so actually from Miss Lee is getting
ready I do want to thank her because
she's actually an employee of the city
of song Nam not a professional
interpreter she was able to come and
she's usually helping a trade promotion
and that kind of event correct yes okay
so mr. mayor thank you very much for
giving us the perspective of a local
government leader into how an Innovation
Centre needs to run cont Dante
perspective little uncle on the pixel of
idiotic a don't even go there in Kosovo
I'm Sunita I'm reminded that in Silicon
Valley
some people have been very successful
and so prices have become very high and
as a result many people have a hard time
living in Silicon Valley one city
manager saw little competitors how
shocking they pissed at the Amidah
so I think your idea of consideration
and coexistence is very important I'll
pay two albums on Sony I don't know King
dong hm you learned throughout your
presentation you talked about failure
and bouncing back and the difficulties
that startup companies face cheddar
chocolate was heads on the harm is all
coming and audio my smile is Meeta and I
would like to ask a little bit more
first of all startup companies fail a
lot no matter what kind of policies we
have Tong Tong take it turns it on their
stubborn whirlen to Bonnie
total opposite hand of Amita so I'm a
little surprised that they would be
popular anywhere
okay Manny tendon and game email not an
engagement doula blubbering comida can
you tell what kind of measures are
available in some for entrepreneurs who
have failed in their business what
happens
Salome's all shape Anand janta ki aapke
durante Takahashi non-pom Tigers in
penguin automata recycle
drunken bull Carson in your Caravan the
shebang jumbo has in your careers and
rates hi guys
there are there is disparity between
what the central government can do and
the local government can do books are
yesterday's engine and I'm sure monkey
in a pitcher I don't intend the most big
the biggest problem in Korea for the
sailors faces that they have to take on
to responsible for the huge individual
debt it's good okay trivalent junk check
to them Chivington Bhutan is a historian
and that Indiana's own that's wrong them
we're certain KK their diameter because
that the policies that could they could
solve the financial problems for those
who fail is not actually local
government can do so the central
government must come up with the
policies to solve the financial problems
Coco Coco each Evangeline Bhutan is her
singing go to the opponent and there
even though we still have the local
government still have some of the
policies that they can help you over to
the Junko ideally young Assad is an
option in Japan she 100 how much from
Havana and you stroke a chunk of my day
with your community want or something
durable damage so locate chuck it at the
hospital Rajan system Cataclysm it
through somnom industry promotion agency
we do have a system support system so
that the startups with ideas can
execute their ideas without spending too
much money and we do financially support
them and also provide them with the
location you'll need a lot would you
notice me if they're really qualified
they can use it for free okay so that's
great from the local government
standpoint let's open the floor my name
is junior I'm I used to live in and well
in three different lea continent in
beginning I started working in North
America and then I moved back to your
career and then worked in Korea and then
I mostly work with the European
companies so different culture have
different businesses ecosystem and
business practice system in India
finally I came to your Silicon Valley I
was a surprise because yeah we have more
disadvantages being here then we have
incentive being here higher living cost
and higher up his rental space
everything is so expensive but here we
can do any business we want even though
it is a gray area between Hoggins high
in gray area it's monotonous it time to
meet a comedian most of urea policies or
aid program or facilitation program is
all to facilitating companies but you
intervene a lot as well
it may I ask for your question I heard
that yes the Camila cannot be replicated
anywhere in the morning anyway anywhere
else in the world
attendance in the company because
Silicon Valley you can do it whatever
you turn but you have a yet facilitation
promotion program but as well as
regulations how do you compromise those
two different objections a common goal I
would give them some Silicon Valley is
about ethical was it nice and crunchy
nut okay
papaya crossing by the ammonia Smita
it's the first time I actually heard
that song has a regulation in Peter gets
her own give it to jamming hydrogen
could on how angle must neither that is
correct that um in Korea generally it is
hard for the failures to bounce back up
they're experiencing setbacks little
fortune get set up inside me and I
believe that fixing it is one of the
duties that I I myself like a politician
has clapping at all listen I'm gonna
head on here do you think I know my own
eyes fear and do not be discouraged
because you still can find plenty of
opportunities in song now I'm looking
young it was it please use on them for
your advantage is an interesting
industry cluster and behind industry
clusters you have clustering where
companies want to come to an area to
respond and cause it taking me repeat
across town or meets pattern engage in
your experience why do companies want to
come to Sonam
Mutombo passed away what almost goddamn
it cold in your pile it and some wonky
of transcendence
bhiku kit.3 fungal Silicon Valley over
sheep pango kilometer in the perspective
of successful companies it is similar
for the successful companies in Silicon
Valley when companies move on wants to
move into Silicon Valley the similar
reason the cookie my voice on Joe
Connelly gaming was a cheat each of your
attempt to Sameera
and besides that the most specific point
I would like to make is that the
location is great go to what she
said--oh samhita also the resists the
living living area is also very nice I
mean with the chip
it's actually the best in Korea
currently yes one in the money
I wish and also there are high competent
talented individuals who live in some
now Chris Orr Sebastian got 0 know what
can I cross the pianola god damn name
Jenga technology Tom and Reza doesn't
gargle tech chicken coop I'll give you
so Jim Howie how you see me so because
of all this attractiveness upon you the
living the cost of living and everything
is going up like he said so we're
actually building another so pangyo
techno Valley in the vicinity
yeah so I'm gonna piss I think that what
I'm gonna good mom questioning me I feel
like it's it's same for all countries
that if it's good it gets expensive I
think that's also good to economic
growth well you have a very big debt
where those debt because of you build
that up that Valley you spend all the
money build it up so you were deep that
he's in your city
it isn't interesting
it's because there was a wasteful
management lemon juice ago Linderman
Booga bang pooja new periodic Timbers
there were previous local government
song which was very corrupted and not
democratic that wasted a lot of money
budgets and became not successful no
Chad Shimano yeah I'm done here worry
did I want to talk when she got it
company listen so after he became
elected he actually solved the problem
in a very simple way in three years and
six months Rajan co-chair kisser
sorry much irony but should carry
groceries by not doing bad things
wrongful doings and saving as much as he
can he was able to do it either in what
portion of a cowboy's opened it oh yeah
you pick it and go
if Jason Chen here D&E there are around
six hundred companies in a specific area
perfect
Peggy okay data you momentum it's
actually a mistake
so aid 870 companies are located in
Hangzhou and also there are 60,000
people working there I mean how does
have a party - and besides that area
there are other industry clusters and so
on
that's not the only cluster yeah I was
going to ask what percentage of size of
jobs in song Dom are in Pangaea you know
how can we say how big Pongo is as part
of some now
yeah chapter xxxii the potent upon GUI
oh yeah we got bottom some economies -
man mentioned all televisions and echo
junior you momentum with a larger pool
of rocky lemme and her momentum did I
get any car was empty
Saruman resize you should put in there
are actually about 20 percent of job
jobs are in Pangu and that is a
comparative out of song nom so there are
actually four hundred thousand jobs in
song them approximately and there are
60,000 jobs in Punggol so that will be
like 20 percent is that correct
thank you that's all your hand so you
mentioned that the top priority should
be protecting small businesses from a
more established business and I was
wondering what those practices and how
if you have some examples of how more
established business that's have abused
their position tong ting tong ting is up
Chung's will be up top one and go to
Bhutan India come on
she give her to me on your gun
it's wrong don't we economy Oh Camilla
actually a business activity as um the
central government plays a huge role in
business activities chapel local linen
yep groovy tunes ok ok a warranty on
network wind encourages Alan she's young
do Akito shebang zombies and Hagar
against transmitters for there are
companies you've heard of chopper
chopper companies in Korea there are the
mega companies in Korea which are
primarily went run by family
members and they are making a difficult
environment for the small and
medium-sized companies to grow in Korea
and the local company local government
has limited a man of restriction for
them kikuchiyo jo guru or magnin gotten
she's young with her Sweden anumita
manon it is hard to structurally stop
stop being from
is it making the system to stop
harassing the big companies harassing
the small companies but it's still
difficult mandarin co-chair chicken kana
was an agonizing interent I'm using
to curse me but local government still
can check and audit if they're they're
following the rules and following system
or not what's wrong with them
remote angers recursion in your abdomen
Charles II throw the key is integrally
on your curry to Catholicism so what
local government can do is not fix them
upside down but incursion by giving them
incentives when they do good things I do
Chango bra gonna turn on cable
monterosso she's an instructor it a
clear Kannan had rope community one yet
its how come she only rather than gee
she's 31 in luck she won't even go
through with she somehow isn't so some
Nome city is giving financial support
and location support when the start when
individuals come to with the great ideas
to make a start up or start a company
she won from Google harmony Akari you
can tidy and hook up depletion ago the
Italian young a tragically mundane
kuznia so dough with hands and throw
rocks a damp young Joe get out pushing
the so the local local government role
is to depress the strong stronger one
and
protect and incubate the less lesser
weaker ones and in some of them we focus
on protecting and growing and incubating
the weaker business if you don't mind
mr. mayor let me comment on this totally
from my perspective not from the city
perspective at all I had lunch yesterday
with a former student who is with a
company that has about 80 people they're
growing very rapidly they're trying to
get a major Korean company to use their
technology and this is a component
technology that would fit inside the
system inside well-known consumer
products and they have to provide so
much information to the Korean company
that they really feel that they cannot
protect their own intellectual property
it starts with source code right so
there has to be so many qualifications
and a lot of what's going on is the big
company is slowing down their access
slowing down their sales process to the
point that if the company is not quite
strong they die before they complete the
sale or the big company develops it
in-house while they're completing the
sale so none of this is really illegal
but it's non-competitive and it happens
when you have a relatively small number
of customer companies so one of the
things that mr. mayor was mentioning
that I thought was very interesting in
this regard is this public monitoring
system that would actually give startup
companies an opportunity to share with
leaders what kind of problems they're
facing because all of these negotiations
between startup company and big company
are completely confidential right so
that's a very interesting idea
tagging company I'll take you up II hope
some head then wooden was premiered
which occurred to me that go look at
them net see them very much and present
monitoring chat about time to enjoy
everything a condor was in there colonia
get access so do you want him to explain
yes that would be great
Korea pageant touch in important who's
you got to either get see man there one
this how was I can come come out ID me
chasing economy hug I get you the
negotiation when it is in process should
be income confidential he agrees but
then afterwards what happened and who
took advantage of who would should be
monitored it says tell you what I don't
even would all gain today get can
generate until Rumaki get amen
our the contact advanced overreacted
again progress with with the name in the
name of freedom and liberty if you give
them all all kinds of freedom to do
whatever they want then of course the
stronger one will oppress depress the
lesser one and we need to prevent that
from happening
turkey targeted a troubling start to
kill forgotten you mean from dominance
from God Grammy Ramadan and companies
small companies such as startups so it
just started needs more protection and
more interest from other public sector
we go tonight for hitting with it just
like we fostered a young the kids in
Iowa or any career de Kooning work
Cody's our challenge I only got
Anya choking Jackie nourishment as
Hodgins how would you go check her go JD
Hogg promotional throw estimate so he
just made a metaphor of when they're
they're having a transaction between
child and adult we as a public sector we
need to intervene and see see if the
transaction is right or not at one point
I saw several hands you go first okay on
the file aside from the language what do
you see as sort of the barriers to entry
for no
Korean for Nationals looking start
companies new companies Satan sub down
are there barriers to entry for foreign
companies
besides language new foreign country
okay Tony Montana young talent family
huh missile startup women did they talk
about their own knowledge and pattern
but the PTO saenggagi no longer to go
I'm little kooky in yeah yeah kind of
China it was up Scottie me things
that the language could be an individual
problem but there there will be a
distinctive difference between if you're
Korean national or not you can get your
octamer and it wasn't sunni director
Chen right there can begin a pretty
collision because of the big competition
there might be a little bit of priority
given to Korean national the stuff its
program is a llama extent politics are a
mere animal I so didn't gonna assume it
is that right that Kurt start start up
its our backs in Stanford I'll gives
priority entrance to the Stanford
students is that right do you know I
will look into that
okay you go may be biased I want to go
back to the slide you had with a list of
companies and I thought what was missing
from that slide where the like the
wattage of multinational high-tech
companies like Google and Microsoft and
although the second generation of Korean
IT companies like pong and ticket
monster and then I think they're all
income nam right
why aren't you able to track those
companies to manage in one day how could
it one way out coo coo and come on
Turkey open slightly lighter than this
Tim Burton good
he said I'm looking easier 30 watts
almond and I saw total opposite of a
meter chromatic number in all right when
they were hungry Simon cool electron has
a do it from you charge up tonight she
was in the Oval de mantequilla
um there are a lot of companies like
those companies wants to move in Topanga
but we really selective selected those
companies which are in Congo right now
is you know valuable we have a specific
guidelines for selecting those companies
and that's how we did we did it ha women
they have no sir no guessing Tom does
her own Kos Committee and we are
expanding like we said before so there
will be more opportunities for those
companies to come in to the second funky
techno Valley
mr. mayor would you talk a bit about
your visit to Seattle yeah go ahead so
many ggs make up some time she got the
IT son of the mill patron attend and OGE
team name Microsoft is are about sitting
this is harbor's from Amazon and boom
job he will give a scimitar because Sam
is a highly technological City it's
highly developed in technology sector so
we decided to go to the Microsoft and
use their City next program and become a
partner with them today
Jacob ever take it easy and we actually
signed the MOU
with them last last week
so this is Microsoft okay okay versus
local naval gains Canyon Jeremy that up
when you have a community German so it's
available you take your cipta take your
cheap planet talk to me the biggest
business sector in Korea face in right
now it's actually the monopoly that's
done by the big companies the chapel
companies that I'd mentioned before
kohaku you know put it on the roll there
is actually a saying of Republic up of
chapter not Republic of Korea and and
that's because of the huge monopoly of
Shepard each apple a Tawonga can get
activated champions and Germany Domingo
Guerra journey some tiny each other
wasn't because of their economic
monopolization of the whole country the
development of the whole country has
been stagnant crystal Javier said own
xavier hasn't killed honest heroine
Yasha call John and Tommy grant a clear
the money yeah Kara mine choices on
Christmas so the majority of the small
and medium-sized companies and startups
and the young people who are starting
business are suffering because of that
to KJ heavily conjuring up human
interaction
she's a young though condom young
everything how wicked M&A chose Hilton
check the news at all he has VA
so guiltiness familiar Budiman egg yolk
tree comes a-huntin to care about
consume it and cheaper companies
actually have a big influence not only
in economies at there but in public
sector as well the politics as well so
they even get the tax policies tailored
to fit their needs instead of the
citizens or the startups so to speak so
that's a huge problem
hockey team on returning home in turin
jangled os10 so call your son Giovanni
Ignace our I'm doing there she conquered
you have a temple Jana Sangh action to
come personally loose women you
determine a gain a young young heir
apparent motive isn't as you know I'm
Koreans there are a lot of Koreans who
have a great talent and great skills but
because of these kinds of disparities
between the chipper and small small and
medium-sized company a lot of those
companies they're not big are have a
hard time growing in Korea
okay so coming with young age I get oh
how cool we have achievement Ubuntu
engaging very convincing a can hard at
work oh great importance from daily come
John Hanke Louisiana she is how Vegas
arrow can get a patent on such a much
own sanchita okay so the things the
homework of the central government and
local government as some lamb city is
has declared the biggest homework of
current homework would be strengthening
the public sector and pub community and
emphasizing on the works works done for
the community and convenience of a
diamond ceramic a cubed Virtua Tennis
have a lot ginger
cotton are seen as high emitter society
that can further develop as a society
where people can
compete in fairness instead of competing
in an unfair situation with these
starter companies that you have become
you how many percentage of them are
privately funded venture capitalist
sounds like your moisture from its
government minggaang Chu an abundant
veteran the percent is entwined a
penguin and keep doing it oh-hoh ask me
that
sorry it does not have a exact number on
it as a mouth but only on screen was
operating under get a clear idea and are
you also expecting any foreign venture
capitalist but what is their advantage
if they decide to invest in one of the
companies what actually let me jump in
okay I think that when you talk about
government funded there's a certain
subsidization of rent there are some
conditions that are given but most of
the companies are really should be
considered private sector companies and
I know that I think it's formation eight
which is a Korea focused venture capital
firm here in Silicon Valley is very
closely involved with Ponyo in fact I
talked with them extensively about it
last year that's one reason I'm so happy
to have this session today
go ahead questions
what percentage of your staff member in
your city managing the batting manager
of alley which is a big job over there
in addition to what you have to every
day as a city
come on deck on Europe wins Mika mm-hmm
it's enough you can't physically it's an
open young Jumbo's and second onee-chan
of indian Tumbo is pushing yourself
she won Quora one-on-one toe jiggy
jung-geun go to a town meeting sana and
Danny and she's me
yeah hyung's and all of which leagues
okay so there are 2500 city official
city employees in song nom City and 20
20 of them work in the business support
team which does works regarding pangyo
techno Valley in City Hall and also
there's 80 of the song number industry
promotion agency employees so together
on 90 of them are there yeah 90 to 100
mr. mayor
thank you for the great about this
market competition
somehow should be controlled and made by
the government as a public function and
also I mean public coming out incubator
for years first at the core track and
now KIC run by mi CPC initiative and
there are chasm and tensions between the
private sectors and the governmental
sectors because government should move
the Pyrenees and regional reasonableness
at the same time I mean while his public
sectors are more focusing on efficiency
and result
so there are to be attentions and
conflicts between two functions are
private and
but at the same time I always find
myself hard to find the way to resolve
these issues because I always have I'm
required to work with the private people
to for the government function so how do
you is there a idea what punctuation all
to replace all this to complete tasks
conditions
speaking in Korean I feel like you speak
Korean yeah okay Tara chungu incubation
s addresses me that is a good result or
beautiful chicken when creates is
exactly the day incubation I thought
that would be on Oh John John sambar a
missile fairly Selena Williams somewhat
I to get in and death how much I don't
open you miss me that community so
choice machine don't have exam or human
I can hunt their damage hungry Chinese
we had a woman then you know I mean I do
so you don't wash machine gun key of G
so you lieutenant gotta go Adam common
component is the yoga English it are
about sundar C's Amina there has to be
disparity between what the public sector
wants and the private sector wants
whatever choice you can give it to me
alone
it's very important to harmonize them
together a single authority will because
everybody has different thought process
goodness no gelatin Yamuna a cornea
curry chicken dish I won't accommodate
indictment in a thousand but I do
believe that public sectors are the
leverage should go up in this in this
world economy so because of the private
sector has become such a strong impact
the more younger car
most times almost sorry what Koreans are
normally classical design she mother
with Mina and the polarization of the
wealth between poor poor and the wealthy
has been worsened Jessica don't want
your timing game oh come on your career
minute she cumin Sanchez Irwin going of
course in the con what there it is
cheeky tied because I always because uh
because we need to fix the polarization
it is a time to strengthen the public
sectors strength okay I think we have
time for maybe one more question and if
you don't mind I would like to ask it so
you've given us a beautiful vision for
the future if we go to Ponyo five years
from now will it be twice as big or will
it be about the same size what what will
we see in the future ok manage on their
own agency penguin optimist appear to be
cosmos big girl John Bonavia not what
written day that will be after his term
how much she put on Pooh Bear Portuguese
huh gorgeous woman a drama yeah I mean
go gay is out of a box she done function
G negative engine button they ask you to
competitive community but he envisions
it to be more than twice bigger than as
now and also it will be the center of
Korean Korean tech sector and a more
moreover it will be what world will be
recognized would recognize Pongal as the
grace text Tech belly s Silicon Valley
the other ones you please come to Pongo
you guys
you